pero tengo que seguir caminando por la línea".
Abajo de la línea.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
¿Cómo se sienten todos hoy? ¿Se sienten bien?
(Aclamaciones)
Fantástico. ¿Les importaría cantar conmigo por solo un segundo?
¿Podrían cantar algo? ¿Podrían cantar un Re?
Canta "Ooh".
(La audiencia tararea)
Oh... más fuerte para mí, más fuerte para mí.
(Cantando) Oh.
Ahora, por favor, si pudieran cantar,
"Oh, oh, oh".
Audiencia: Oh, oh, oh.
Jacob Collier: Gua, oh, oh.
Audiencia: Gua, oh, oh.
JC: Canta, "Gua, oh".
Audiencia: Gua, oh.
JC: Oh, oh, oh.
Audiencia: Oh, oh, oh.
JC: Canta, "Gua, oh, oh".
Audiencia: Gua, oh, oh.
JC: Gua, oh, oh.
JC: Canta, "Gua, oh, oh".
Audiencia: Gua, oh, oh.
Muchas gracias. Eso es hermoso. Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
¿Sienten ese movimiento?
¿Se sienten como parte de ese movimiento,
cosas que se mueven debajo de la superficie?
El lenguaje de la armonía musical es absolutamente extraordinario.
Es una forma de navegar por los marcos emocionales de uno,
pero sin la necesidad de ponerlo en palabras,
y creo que, como en muchos otros idiomas,
no importa cuánto sabes sobre un idioma.
No importa cuántas palabras puedas decir,
cuantas frases conoces.
Importan las elecciones emocionales que haces con este lenguaje.
Me animo a adoptar esta idea como comunidad,
que es lo que con el tiempo puede hacernos crecer hacia
opuesto a alejarnos de nuestra propia humanidad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Música)
(Cantando) Tómame
a donde quieras ir.
Sabes que mi amor es fuerte.
En mi escondite
Suavemente,
como la calma que sigue a las tormentas,
Encuentra lo que he estado buscando todo el tiempo.
En mi escondite
Incluso cuando cierro los ojos,
Cariño, si te has extraviado, me dirijo a mi escondite.
Tócame
como nunca antes he amado,
en el lugar que adoro,
en mi escondite
Lo sé
cualquiera que sea la dirección del viento,
habrá un lugar para ir
en mi escondite
Mi escondite,
palos y piedras
no me esconderé de ti más.
Y con el tiempo
encuentro lo que he estado buscando.
Escuchó tu voz
llamándome.
Voy en camino
a donde puedo ser libre.
Y si ella no quiere esperar por mí, hazlo bien, no mires atrás,
mantén mi corazón en el futuro
En las suelas de mis zapatos todos los lugares donde he estado
eso lo he sabido desde que la conocí.
Porque eres tú, no sabes que me estás haciendo adivinar
que eres la indicada para mí
Que eres tú y creo que quería saber todo el tiempo.
Nena, eres tú lo que quiero, lo que me hace completo,
porque eres la indicado para mí.
Es gracias a ti que creo que quiero que sepas a que pertenezco.
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias. Gracias.
Gracias.
Muchas gracias. Gracias chicos.
Kelly Stoetzel: Bien, Jacob. Guau.
Bien, tenemos algunas preguntas. JC: Bueno.
KS: Eso fue espectacular.
JC: Gracias, Kelly. Gracias.
KS: Las visualizaciones que acabamos de ver,
se estaban dando en tiempo real, ¿verdad?
JC: Sí, todo lo visual
toma pistas de cosas que son audibles, o algo así, si es la palabra,
y todo es en tiempo real.
Señalo los bucles, toco los instrumentos
y luego el árbol, por ejemplo, que viste crecer,
crece de tal manera que toma notas bajas largas
y crece en gruesas ramas largas,
y toma notas altas y suaves, lo que sea, y luego crecen ramas finas y pequeñas.
Y luego mi voz cantando
como golpes de viento contra el árbol.
KS: Tienes 22 años. JC: Sí, de hecho.
Moderador: Tocaste todo esto solo.
¿Cómo comenzó y cómo evolucionó todo esto?
JC: Tengo una habitación mágica en mi casa
en el norte de Londres, que está, como, allí.
(Aclamaciones)
Gracias. Representa North London.
Y esta habitación... quiero decir, es mi casa familiar.
Crecí en esa habitación llena de instrumentos musicales,
pero lo más importante, tenía una familia
que me animó a invertir en mi propia imaginación,
y lo que creé, las cosas que construí, eran buenas cosas para construir
solo porque las estaba haciendo, y creo que esa es una idea tan importante.
Pero esa habitación era mi paraíso,
y cuando vine a presentar mi álbum, que se llama "In My Room"
pensé que trataría de presentar la habitación en el camino,
y esa es una idea muy extraña,
pero es algo en lo que he estado trabajando por un par de años,
y es muy emocionante estar dentro del círculo.
KS: Esta es realmente la configuración en tu habitación, aquí.
JC: Algo parecido. Es similar a la habitación
en el sentido de que puedo generar cosas en el acto
y puedo ser espontáneo,
que es de lo que creo que se trata tanto la música como todas las mejores ideas.
KS: Ganaste dos Grammys
por un disco que hiciste en tu habitación por ti mismo.
¿Y cómo es eso posible? No podríamos haber hecho eso,
eso no podría haber sido hace 5 años, incluso.
JC: Es un mundo nuevo.
El poder ahora está en manos del creador,
estoy seguro de que estarían de acuerdo
opuesto al gran ejecutivo de la discográfica
o el gran hombre o algo así.
Es alguien con una buena idea.
Estoy en TED diciéndoles esto chicos que ya lo saben,
pero es alguien con una buena idea quién puede sembrar esa semilla.
Esa es la persona que lleva la antorcha al mundo.
Y sí, hice este álbum completamente solo
y no esperé a que alguien dijera:
"Jacob, deberías hacer un álbum por tu cuenta".
Solo seguí y lo logré y no me importó lo que la gente pensara,
y dos Grammys son una bonificación masiva.
(Aplausos)
KS: Muchas gracias, Jacob. JC: Gracias, Kelly. Muchas gracias.